Hello and welcome to this video on Navigation Invokers. So what is a Navigation Invoker?
A Navigation Invoker generates a navigation mesh with the data on the fly around the actor
which the component is attached to. These are fantastic for dynamically generated worlds
anywhere it's too large that you don't want to maintain a nav mesh for the entire world.
It's great for open world games and it will just create a nav mesh around the specific
actor which has this component on it. Usually a pawn. So let's go into the engine and have a
look at how you would go about setting these up. All right, so here we are back in the engine.
So if you want to set up Navigation Invokers, there's a couple of things that you need to do.
So the first thing is I have an open world here and I have added a nav mesh balance volume.
Okay, so that is going to still define where the nav mesh is created.
If you don't have this, there'll be no nav mesh created. So you can go away and then just
add it to the entire world and it won't create a nav mesh for the entire world,
it'll only create it at runtime dynamically around an Invoker. So feel free to make this
big. Now what we need next is to change some of the project settings. So within navigation,
in the project settings, the two things that you're looking for is, first of all,
runtime generation. So under here we have nav mesh, runtime generation has to be dynamic.
We're going to be building this at runtime quite a lot, so make sure that this is set
to dynamic. Next up we have to set the generate navigation only around the Navigation Invokers.
So those are the two settings that you have to change. You have to make sure the runtime
generation is set to dynamic and that generating navigation only around the Invoker is checked.
Okay, and once this is done, if you press the P key, you're not going to see anything any.
So we're going to be able to unable to actually see when this is generated.
Okay, now that means that we're going to have to jump into the engine to see this running.
But we need to do one more thing, and that is any actor that you want navigation to be
generated around, you have to add in a component. So here I have our BP top-down character,
and I am going to add a nav navigation invoker. Here we see this, and that's going to add it
to our character. And from this, I'm going to change some of the settings.
So this navigation section here is important because it's going to do a couple of different
things. The first thing is it's going to get us to define how far away we want to generate
the tiles up to, and how far away a tile needs to be before it is removed from the generation.
So you'll always want the removal radius to be bigger than the generation radius,
and depending on your tile sizes, I'd make it relatively large. Okay, so by default it's set
to 3000 and 5000. This is a bit big for our needs because we're not going to be able to see
it relatively easily. So I'm going to cut this down to 500, and the removal at about 1000.
Now under this we have supported agents, and this is going to reflect the agents which you've
created within the project settings. But what is important is you're going to generate the nav
mesh for any of these which are here. So standardly, you really want to
untick any which are not relevant to the pawn that you're using. There are some other
different cases. Sometimes you might want to use a navigation invoker on some other kind of actor,
and you might want to have all of the supported agents. But because we're doing this
around our character, and we know this character is going to fall into the default agent,
I can untick the wide. I'll leave it ticked for the moment just so that we can see that it
creates this. Okay, so that's up and running. Now I'm going to jump back into the engine,
and I'm going to push play, and I'm going to push tilde, and then I'm going to type in
show navigation, and that's going to bring up the navigation mesh. And you'll see here,
if I click off this navigation mesh, the character cannot figure out the pathfinding.
However, if I click on it, it can move, and the navigation mesh is going to update as I get
closer. I've set this to quite a small number so that we can see it functioning. Now you'll
see at the moment that I can't see the nav meshes which are coming up. So if I
jump in and find our recast, select wide, and in the details panel, I'm going to tick so that it
is drawn. Where is that? So enable drawing, and you can see that both of these nav meshes are
getting drawn. So at any point where I'm running this, this is going to have to build two nav
meshes, and one of them is never going to be used. So that is just wasted time. However,
if I untick the wide, and run the game again, and again do show navigation, and
enable drawing, you can see that it's now no longer created it. So it is important,
especially if you're placing this on the Pawn, that you limit the navigation generation to just
that Pawn. If you had a second creature which was large and fit in a different agent,
you would set that nav mesh to generate as wider, and it would generate its own nav mesh,
even if they overlap. So that is navigation in VOCUS. Usually you'd set them to a larger size,
but very useful for larger worlds where you don't want to have to manage a very large nav
mesh. Thank you very much.